[Laughter]  hi i'm natasha Lyonne I play Nicky  Nichols on orange is the new black and  these are some season two spoilers in  the season finale the other prisoners  hold my character down and run a brush  through my hair crazy eyes will fall in  love with a new inmate batshit legs  she's hot as [ __ ] here's what happens  seriously the prison gets sold to Ikea  and the ladies spend all of season two  assembling - Gorgon bookshelves we've  got a big exciting change to the opening  credits more highs there's a new warden  in town Dustin Diamond the mystery  chicken is getting its own spin-off show  it's a police drama called Kappa  doodle-doo in Episode two there's a big  prison break but most of us are in the  shower so we don't notice because we're  having sex with each other with our  fists and mouth root beer  you need to cop down the prison it's  supposed to Ikea  [Music]